welcome to the program the UK's Finance
Minister Jeremy Hunt has declared his
nation is in recession the chancellor of
the exchequer also said he expects the
economy to shrink even further in the
next fiscal year Hunters laid out his
plans to tackle soaring inflation he's
included raising taxes for higher
earners more people with an income of
148 000 or more will have to pay at
least 45 percent tax rate hunt expects
public spending to slow down to help
make up the 65 billion dollars needed to
bolster the state's budget but he
pledged more help for the elderly and
low-income households he also increased
the windfall tax on oil and natural gas
companies from 25 to 35 percent and
that's expected to raise 16 and a half
billion dollars next year
today we set our country a new National
ambition by 2030 we want to reduce
energy consumption from buildings and
Industry by 15 percent reducing Demand
by this much means in today's prices a
28 billion pound saving from our
national Energy bill or 450 pounds off
the average household bill
this must be a shared Mission with
families and businesses playing their
part
but so will the government play our part
let's bring in Andrew Simmons who's
following events for us from London
Andrew it's very detailed presentation
of the financial situation of the mess
really that the UK is in and what needs
to be done to balance the books
very much so 38 billion US dollars worth
of cuts and raising something like
28.5 billion dollars worth of tax Rises
now it's a thing called fiscal drag
which economists use as a term for
what's happened with income tax income
tax has been increased effectively by
shifting this not shifting the
thresholds but just simply leaving them
alone they're normally increased with
inflation or somewhere near to inflation
also the highest earners are going to be
hit the worst because the threshold has
been adjusted downwards there so really
you've got everybody in Britain having
to pay more tax Furthermore with the
cost of living increasing and and an
inflation rate of 11.1 which is the
highest since well since 40 years
um there is a real worry about energy
still because they there is a system of
subsidy but it's going to be decreased
in its amount across across the board
apart from targeted amounts to to more
vulnerable people which will they will
see considerable increases but what the
conservative party is trying to do with
its tactics here is try to to actually
project a caring in some areas and
trying to be more responsible with their
budgets but really one has to question
that because uh something well billions
uh dollars worth of cuts have been
stalled for two years effectively until
after the next election so an evident
move there to try to get away from the
negative side of it but looking at other
aspects to the uh this this whole Autumn
statement there are a few things
surprises such as electric vehicles
owners were
excluded from having to pay the vehicle
a charges taxes for them now they will
in August in
2025 April 2025 they will have to pay
the amount furthermore there is the
Health Service which is getting a
moderate increase there is the Education
Service getting an increase and social
care also but that's all going to be
overtaken by inflation so the the
central theme Here is that this is a
depressing time for Britain no doubt and
just think 55 days ago the Prime
Minister Liz trust was talking about tax
cuts and a growth economy quite the
contrary now indeed Andrew Simmons there
for us in London thank you Sandy